unless y'all you know it I don't know if
we'll always use this song but we are
today happy holidays guys happy early
holidays kickin pigeons baby kicking
pigeons on a stone is that week baby
braid your cousin's hair tickle yourself
man
do it I dare you want me to slap that
Park and braid
and tell you
find a song sing it yeah oh you thank
you guys for being here
happy Thanksgiving week it is November
in the year of 2018 and you got oh yeah
I know you can hear it and you know we
got a still wall we all still got a
little bit of work to do this week but
you can you can hear the wheels of of
the busy year you can hear those brakes
starting to lock up and you can hear
them you can hear the year starting to
grind to a halt and man it is kind of
nice it is kind of and if you're still
going real hard take a deep breath you
know take a hit off the universe and
bring it down
do something relaxing you know you know
tickle somebody feel how soft you know
like a senior citizen is there like a
you know take your dog for a walk try to
read a book I mean we're so scattered
our I'm so scattered these days I can't
barely read but every now and then you
know I try to read and that's like the
old reading a book is just trying to
read one but do something you know hug
somebody it's Thanksgiving week hoot I
thought of this if you want to send in
and I a clip of it's called relative
rodeo and that's hashtag relative rodeo
and that's that Thanksgiving you got a
hug a relative that maybe don't really
want a hug from you and somebody else in
your family have to film it and you got
to stay on for as long as you can
so it's a wild game but in the end you
know a lot of times that can bring
people closer together
but that if you want to send that in to
me hashtag relative rodeo I'll be
peeping some of those but no for no fake
ones man don't send in you know I need a
tie I want to I want to see somebody go
in eight seconds you don't want to see
somebody really hitting it hard out
there
Dallas buyer clubbing don't come in you
know with you cheating and it's just you
and somebody you already our friends
with or you know we're doing sex within
your family or not you know a lie I mean
a wife or a you know fiance or something
I want to see that real relative rodeo
but if you want to send that to me and
make it a hashtag relative Rodion social
medias what else man oh I yeah I can
just hear the year grinding to a halt
and I can feel I can feel some peace man
I had a nice time at I just had a nice
weekend just relaxing really I really
did you know just kind of chilling out
and you know I've been going through
some things and you guys have you know
some of the listeners have been really
supportive and sent some nice messages
in and I'm grateful for that you know
and I just realize I'm grateful to just
be alive and still be able to learn even
at this age and even at this point in my
life to still be able to have the
opportunity to be alive in this
playground and be able to experience
life and experience some of the things
that are going on whether they be highs
or lows or you know just learning
experiences you know I've been I've met
a lot of wonderful people so far in my
life and a lot of them are you guys and
thank you guys for being a part of this
this past year we're coming up on two
years of this past weekend it's so crazy
it's you know when I think about it it's
uh it's just it's cool it's cool and
we're gonna do some great things I want
to thank all the patreon supporters and
I'm gonna thank them by name at the end
of the podcast and I want to thank all
the listeners and everybody that's been
coming out
helping us do some neat things you know
the single moms you know we're gonna put
out our gameshow episode of uh get that
cash which is hiding the hotel room
money for the cleaning lady and and then
you know I want to continue to
incorporate some other ideas and do
other fun stuff that makes me feel good
honestly and and we do a lot of that
together and I'm grateful for you guys
thank you thank you very much happy
Thanksgiving to you from me I love this
time of year you know I remember at this
time of year when I was young you know
the carnival sometimes would come by you
know when it was kind of cool enough
maybe that was August or something but
in the fall the carnival would come by
and they had remember one time when I
was a child they had a you know somebody
set the cart the ferris wheel and a
ferris wheel was like it's basically
like deja vu but like on a big metal
machine so if you ever had deja vu but
it's like that it's like somebody made a
machine out of it and you get on there
and usually the guy that's letting you
on the ferris wheel he you ask him a
question about safety or how long you're
gonna be on or anything like that and he
won't he can't hear you has no answers
or no information I mean sometimes -
he'll be wearing like these big you know
earmuffs he's big Air Force earmuffs and
they're these earmuffs they made so when
you're in the Air Force you can pretend
like you're not and sometime you'll see
guys having them on airfields and stuff
and and so basically this guy who you're
asking information for this that was
operating the rod he couldn't [ __ ]
hear you and then he would lock you in a
cage man he would lock you in this kind
of caged up deal
and then he would started off and just
start you just spinning around through
the same moment over and over again and
I remember one time they set this they
set the arm
they set the one time they set the
ferris wheel up the ride up to close to
a a tree a oak tree or a you know we're
like a haunted maple or something you
know but it looked like an oak and they
had a wasps nests up there and dude I
don't know if I remember a more
harrowing experience you know and this
was me and my boy Robert and he had this
internal whisper going on where you know
Robert would you know he was like he I
think I've talked about him before he
was like kind of supposed to be twins
but he never separated and so he always
you would hear him say something and say
it you'd hear it echo again inside of
him you know he'd be like I want a
sandwich I want a sandwich he'd be like
oh man I had too much gravy at dinner I
had too much gravy at dinner you know he
would say something again under his
breath he had repetitive verbal syndrome
or something
so anyway dude you get on this Ferris
wheel and this [ __ ] is just taking you
over and over again through the wasps
every kid on the thing screaming crying
getting stung people jumping off the
[ __ ] little I remember [ __ ] Daniel
hit the air bro right I'll just jump
probably 90 feet off this route and who
knows into what nobody I don't even know
what happened to him but this man had
set the dang Ferris wheel up under a
wasps nest and I mean every time we went
back there it was just like us just it
was our you OH Jima man it was just like
trying the beaches of Normandy just over
and over and again you know when just
just oh man we was just out there
Dunkirk and just getting just torn our
ass up every time you know you think you
and you'd go down and then the next the
kids behind you were going in
scream and just getting washed up all
because of some jackass in the guy
you're screaming he can't hear you
he had on the super airforce head
setters and God I remember that that was
miserable but I remember we got off of
it and you know they had probably
probably maybe 16 17 kids that had been
washed up you know one boy just he'd to
know what the [ __ ] was going on somebody
somebody was dripping you know dripping
diesel under his tongue or something
putting kerosene in his mouth or
something you know they're trying to
this was back when they didn't know how
to solve a lot of you know medical
issues but they gave everybody free
cotton candy and I remember going from
such a low of like damn you know Here I
am at the fair want the one thing around
the area that I can afford every year
and I'm excited about and now I'm
walking around all stung and and the
cotton candy did help I remember that
you know I do remember that but I just
loved this time of year when the air was
different and things were a little more
still and you could hear uh you know
there wasn't as many animals because
where I grew up they had a lot of
animals you know crickets you know not
vultures but you know Angry Birds you
know like you know you know kind of
ducks but I had it some violence in them
you know sparrows eat up nightingales
trying to you know land in people's I
froze and [ __ ] like that and I remember
it just and at this time of year a lot
of the animals went to Barbados or you
know done a the southern hemisphere and
so you got a little relaxation you
wouldn't hear all the animals you know
doing sex or just being around each
other you wouldn't hear a lot of that
you know fighting or whatever you know
procreate and or anything so you got
more or just stillness in the air and I
always loved that about this time of
year but damn I'll never forget that
[ __ ] man that dude set that freaking
ferris wheel up onto that wasps nests
and every time we went through man and
it was crazy we went through some things
you know we went through some things
together back then and now that my buddy
Robert man haunted Robert and he seemed
very haunted you know because I think he
was supposed to be twins but they never
separated in the womb and so we always
had you know his little you know this
little bad-boy sibling inside of him
lurking you know he was that double
entendre you know that you know he was
that confluence you know he was that uh
you know he had a little bit of reverb
going on inside of his DNA and that was
a special time though you know what
actually reminded me of that recently I
was in the airport and I was in
Minnesota Airport and mental of
Minnesota Airport people are nice they
got them scratchers they got the UM the
scratch off lottery tickets because
nothing you know if you want to [ __ ]
take a chance I like to be able to take
a chance every now and then and in the
old days you could do different stuff to
take a chance you know you could uh you
could commit a crime back in the day
they didn't have a DNA or any they had a
wanted poster that was it they have one
dudes drawing of you so all you had to
know was it you know how good the local
artist was and if they were [ __ ] then
you could do a crime you could take a
chance you know do a robbery or do her
um a burglary or do something but now
taking a chance you know it's harder to
take a chance and that's why I like some
time they have um
scratch off ticket machines them
scratchers and and they're domiciled up
there in those you know in these little
things in the airport but anyway so
oh.what reminding me of the being on the
ferris wheel was somebody let some of
their booty
you know body gas out of there but at
the on the electric floor escalator yes
at Minnesota Airport and this was I'll
see what date it was in case anybody
else's over there this was November 4th
probably this was like about 8:30 8:00
to 8:30 a.m. I don't feed my family else
caught this you know this cloud but this
I mean somebody unleashed their whole I
mean it was almost like somebody had a
ghost hiding in there but you know and
this thing just suddenly just haunted
started haunting the universe right
there in the airport and somebody did it
on the on the moving floor that moving
escalator so man you it just flashed
back dude you had and I went down and
got lost because I was going supposed to
be Indy and I went to II so next thing
you know I went through it twice so you
know dude that has had this big you know
big
vulgar sort of you know this big vulgar
sort of metamorphosis air bubble out
there that somebody had you know
straight up launched out of them out of
their body just on this escalator so
people were just moving through it just
move and just
oh man I bet I don't know if somebody
was just like a damn Dexter just sitting
off to the side just watching that go
down but that was but it reminded me of
going up on that ferris wheel and going
through the wasp and just coming back
around and going through the wasps you
know because we were just we had no we
couldn't we couldn't stop we couldn't
stop it
we couldn't stop it and that was um that
was pretty powerful there and that was
in a Minnesota Airport but then I went
through it once I was like I was angry
and you know I'll get angry in my head
at people I don't know and then you know
I start kind of getting racial and
everything and just who knows
so I'm cursing out all these people in
my head and and uh and then I realize
that I went to the wrong terminal so I
went back through it so at that point
I'm like dude you're an idiot you know
you're dissing you know you're just a
dang an air idiot anyway you don't know
what's in the air sometimes and you'll
go through it twice so definitely you
know really an air idiot
bye but I do love this time of year and
I just you know I remember the carnival
growing up we would go to and
Thanksgiving like school was taking a
break and I remember we would do it
Thanksgiving I mean I oh we would see
sometimes my grandparents a lot and they
would cook or you know my mom would do
some cooking and it was really nice you
know it was just a nice I don't think we
were a big Thanksgiving family but it
was just a nice time of year cuz we got
to play football outdoors and our street
man I'll tell you one thing I loved
about growing up on Magee Street in
Covington Louisiana was that we played
football and I'm wearing right now I got
this Barry Sanders from roots of fight
they gave me this sweet little blue top
and then this thing feels good it's a
sweatshirt and a sweatshirt is just a
shirt that's trying to you know trying
to get you to feel even more gentle
and and we will play football man we
would get out there I mean we played
almost I bet we played 200 days a year
after school we'd go down to the church
parking lot and church a field they had
a big feel by the church near us and we
would get down there and play it man it
felt good you know it just felt if it
was just fun it was fun man it was one
thing that we all in the area did
together and sometimes the big boys
would come and just beat the foot you
know they would play but really their
only goal was to beat us just physically
beat everybody's ass you know the score
would be nothing nothing we'd kick it
off to them and it would be first down
for them and then they would just beat
everybody's ass and that was it that was
the whole game there was no real game it
was just you know kind of like
self-defense but you know there was like
a football you know around us oh but it
was a fun time man I had some sets this
weekend at the comedy store I saw Joe
Rogan's that was cool
I saw we have some good guests coming up
this week we have which ones where we're
taping we have some episodes coming up
or we have some episodes coming up
ronald white you know one of my mother's
favorite comedian ronald white or on
white donnell rawlings beautiful black
gentleman you know I feel like he and I
have we have some great conversations
I'm really looking forward to that he's
one of my favorites and Jim Jefferies
and Jim Jefferies is an Australian who's
here on work visa and uh and he may be
taking advantage of the system who knows
but we'll see
but I'm very excited Man 3 you know
three men that I certainly admire and
look up to and their comedic abilities
and prowess what else yeah I've got some
nice calls man I was having a tough time
last week and I'm still going through
some stuff you know on a personal level
you know I'm just thankful I guess that
I'm still able to grow you know that I'm
still I was trying to you know I really
want to focus this week on being
thankful
and just and just getting outside of
myself you know one thing that makes me
sick sometime I get sick of myself I
don't know if that I I think it's just
this era in this time or that you know
this me generation type of thing and
it's not even a generation it's a me
culture you know I noticed the other day
when I was and I've noticed this enough
times where now it's become like a
hypothesis I guess but or a theory but
when you get out when an elevator opens
now the people who are automatically
trying to get in first now you notice
that and it used to be nothing like that
it used to be the elevator open you
waited to see who was there they were
coming out but now that's not the case
the set if you're in the elevator the
second it hits the floor the doors open
whoever's there is already getting in
and I know that it sounds like well that
is that's nothing T oh that's nothing
and put to me that seems like you know
like more like we're just so much in our
own heads that we don't even think that
somebody else could be in the box you
know we don't think about that and it's
and that that's almost and I've and I
could be crazy but I think I've noticed
that enough from like oh this is a real
thing and I even noticed myself do it
sometimes like oh I'm trying to go in
these doors aren't even really open yet
and these people still have to come out
of the elevator and so that's when I
start to think oh well if I'm noticing
it and I'm doing it it's just something
that's starting to occur in the world
and then I start to think well why is
this starting to occur and I think it's
just because we're all thinking just
that we're on our own paths as opposed
to were on a group path so this this
week I want to hit some more you know
yeah you know I go to a meetings and
stuff like that and some 12-step and
just stuff - I don't want it I'm just
tired of thinking about myself
does anybody else feel I'm just kind of
sick of myself like not in a bad way but
just
it's just like man haven't we had enough
of ourselves it
like we just every moment there's news
and information and humanity humanity
humanity but but so trivialized because
it's so redundant that it's you know I
just I just I don't know I want
something that I don't know it's just
like I could just use a little bit and I
mean this in a positive way this isn't
like a you know some kind of plea for up
I just I'm tired of thinking about my
I'm tired of this you know our brains
are you know the software isn't I don't
think it doesn't super fit well with
some of the times and I think my
software is just tired of running you
know so I just need to you know I'm
excited to just kind of go to some
meetings that gets me out of my head it
makes me think about others and when I
can when I can hear somebody else's
story and hear them share pieces of
their lives and things that mean
something to them that's when I feel
that you know I really feel warmed up by
the world and I feel more hopeful so
that's something today's episode we
brought to you by Ridge wallet everybody
you know I saw a man yesterday he had a
Ridge wallet and right out the gate I
had to hug him you know not only hugged
him for maybe a second or two but that's
still a hug and that's the beauty of
Ridge wallet it brings things together
like things you used to keep in your
back pocket suddenly those things are up
in the front Oh where's all your stuff I
know right in your [ __ ] pocket dude
where it should be
Ridge wallet keeps the things you need
no more you know sometime someone will
have a wallet with something like a damn
butterscotch or something in it get the
[ __ ] out of here Henry that's [ __ ] up
regular stuff
regular wallet Ridge that front pocket
carry visit Ridge wallet comm slash Theo
and use code Theo at checkout for ten
percent
that's Ridge wallet dot-com slash Theo
and use code Theo for ten percent off
Ridge wallet that front pocket carry
what else oh dude I remember when I was
a child they had
this dude mr. Lance that lived by us and
he had this monkey right and one time it
was Thanksgiving I think our Christmas
break but I think it was Thanksgiving
because I don't remember you know when I
think about the memory I don't you know
think about like I don't hear a lot of
jingle bells in the background of the
memory and mr. Lance had this monkey and
you know it was a regular monkey some
people thought it was a cat like a UH
some people at first for a little while
thought it was a child in a little suit
a little costume but it was a monkey and
I saw I eventually saw it and it was
definitely a monkey right well dude we
go over there some of the older boys I
remember Thanksgiving we went over there
and and for you know I don't know how
much they gave him but you know a couple
dollars the monkey if you got up close
by the cage the monkey would pull your
hair right and while it was pulling it
would arm you know we were dog you know
do to do some masturbation you know
spray out and you know what I believe
that we maybe evolved from monkeys that
God created right that's where my kind
of beliefs are you know I'm kind of in
that middle ground you know I think
we're definitely there's I think there's
something more special about us than
just being part of kingdom Animalia but
when you see a monkey masturbate that's
when I was like oh there's no way that
we're like down because they do it I
mean this this little guy was like the
damn riddick bowe of jerking off you
know this was you know sugar ray ah this
was Sugar Ray Leonard's of jerking off
this little thing you know this monkey I
mean he was using both hands he was
using the back of his hands front of his
hands he was at one point he took his
own dick off and just juggled it in the
air until it came until it sprayed
and I'm like jeepers you know we can't
do that so that's one really some of the
stuff for me kind of started to separate
I guess when you look at that sort of
deal but but I remember man a couple
bucks we go over there and the older
boys would get this thing they would
hold up they would hold the monkey would
hold reach out the cage and hold their
hair pulled her hair real tight and
something about that created sexuality
in the monkey you know in a second he
started pulling their hair he would get
real fired up and he would you know go
over and exacerbate himself or whatever
you know do himself out with his hand
you know make part of his body just in a
little bit of a you know water like kind
of thick water come out of the front of
him and it was it was [ __ ] wild I
guess man I don't know it was Mother
Nature this before they had the nature
Channel so this is back when if you saw
something exciting like that you just
kind of treasured it and you know it was
that was our nature Channel I guess now
they got the nature Channel you can
watch anything you want on the Internet
you know you can you can watch for bison
in a gang you know doing 69s or whatever
you know you could watch two animals
kind of kiss in or you know you could
watch a hippopotamus [ __ ] you know
caressing a doves wing if you want me
there's all there's everything but when
we had it you had to go see the nature
you had to go see the nature and you had
to see the nature up front and those are
some things that I miss about being
young and and just this time of year man
and mr. Lantz
I don't know how that dude had a monkey
but back then every couple people had a
monkey you know what now it's like some
[ __ ] lose our next G on Twitter I
swear it's 5,000 people on Twitter
ruining the [ __ ] world that's what I
think it is people crying about this and
complaining about this I mean man
someone
[ __ ] has just gone too much you know and
I do think that some of that kind of
like more relaxed culture is gonna start
to come back into us and we're gonna you
know hopefully start to chill out a
little but mr. Lance had that monkey man
and it was you know the cage was kind of
gold it was like a gold cage it wasn't
real gold but when you're a kid you
think it's real gold she think oh man
you know mr. Lance got that real a
special primate he has a special
creature here and so then that's why the
older boys they had a little bit of
money I didn't have any money so I had
to watch their you know their ride you
know they had to watch their you know
you see a monkey grab a boy's hair and
start jerking off man it makes you think
about evolution you know and so I guess
there was some real positives with that
but that was something that happened at
Thanksgiving what else Oh
my mother would always get mad because
she would give us a little cutter that
jellied cranberry you know some people
get the cranberry it's got real
cranberries in it and you can tell a
families are you could tell a family how
real they are you know you could tell
how many gang signs of family uses by
what style of cranberry they got at
Thanksgivings cuz where I'm from we had
that jelly deal you know we had that
little look like a little batch of
science had made it you know and [ __ ]
one year my mom just put a damn thing of
concord grape out there she put it in
the freezer for about an hour and a half
and set that [ __ ] on the table and we
all had just you know [ __ ] grape jam
you know and just lied to ourselves but
usually with the cranberry you know when
we had it we could when we got the real
cranberry jelly we my mother would cut
us off a slice of that and we get that
you know if you were lucky you got maybe
about an inch and a quarter thick of
that that jellied you know a jellied
Wonderland that crammed bay
and then but then as kids we start you
know we would all draw a little dicks in
it or do little you know religious
crosses or something or you know Mickey
Mouse ears you know fun shapes but and
then they had wealthier people you went
to their house and they had it was more
like a um it was like the jelly but it
had real cranberries in there and that
real cranberries from you know from God
or vegetables or whatever in the jelly
so it was like this double thing and it
tasted like more like it tasted not as
like good it kind of bothered you a
little bit when you tasted it it tasted
kind of good and kind of like bothersome
you know and like kind of like head lice
you know kind of fun but kind of [ __ ]
also you know not as fun and then they
had even richer people would just have a
bowl of real cranberries right there and
I don't know if you ever had real
cranberries but they're disgusting they
taste like they taste like you're just
so rich that you don't even you know
that you don't even you would sacrifice
good good taste for just looks that's
what it tastes like
so when you see real rich people they
just have a bowl of cranberries right
there and they'll put damn cinnamon on
them or something or you know olive oil
or something or some [ __ ] you know
snake
you know snake you know snake dust or
something some [ __ ] fancy
accoutrement powder or whatever they'll
put on top of it and then you eat that
and you're like damn man I miss being
[ __ ] poor cuz this stuff tastes like
[ __ ] but but yeah you could tell a lot
by a fan you know where a family is and
how many gang signs they use and who
they are as people by you know that
cranberry that Salt's chart and that's
something special you can think about
this holidays
ah what else man I'm gonna do some shows
this week oh I have some shows to
announce I'll announce a couple right
now and they are I'm not announcing
everything yet I got a bunch of new tour
dates for the new year
they are Omaha and that's January 11th
and 12th at the Omaha funny bone and
then Irvine improv that's January 18th
19th and 20th but yeah I want to say you
know I guess I does I want to say thank
you you know I want to say thank you
guys for your support you know even just
this week man I got a lot of nice calls
you know one of the guys who helped with
the who helped with the single mom thing
in Salt Lake City last week heard the
podcast and he's like yeah he gave me a
call and said you know he seemed like I
was having kind of a tough time and and
I think I have been man in some ways you
know I'm not trying to get like emo or
nothing but you know this year has just
been kind of wild for me you know and
it's been a lot of changes and I'm not
like crying about the fact like I'm
grateful for the fact that you know I'm
getting more opportunities with work and
stuff like that you know but I think
part of me you know I just feel you know
like I just want to be better on the
inside you know like sometimes that us
don't feel always okay you know and it's
you know and that's where I want to be
you know that's where I want to feel
good at you know it was inside of my
heart and and uh you know I don't know
if it's just part of the times we're in
or maybe it's just me but sometimes you
know I just wonder if we're all not like
missing like some crucial piece some
element that we're not seeing sometimes
that there's something bigger out there
as far as how we can feel more joy and
that could be like just a regional thing
it could be like an American thing
you know I know certainly in my in my
area in Los Angeles there lacks a lot of
that you know it's just such a busy
place it's more of an office than it is
more of a more of like an emotionally
kind of connected place you know it's
really it's very trying you know and I'm
grateful to be out here and be battling
then it so I have to recognize sometimes
that you know I'm living in a place that
doesn't cater to you know to emotional
well-being as much as it's much more
emotionally efficient out here but I
appreciate it man I just got a lot of
nice calls and stuff like that and man
you guys um you know it's nice it makes
me feel good you know cuz sometimes I
don't feel okay you know when sometimes
I want to be you know I don't know
sometimes I just you know I just wanna I
don't know I just want to be okay you
know and I just want to live a life that
you know makes me feel worthwhile and
some of the moments that I've had that
it may be most feel that way honestly
I've been through this podcast I know
that sounds kind of crazy but you know
just the calls that come in and you know
in the little things we do sometimes
like the calls you know what gets me man
the calls that come back in you know
somebody will call in they're having an
issue or something you know they gotta
you know they got bit by an atom or you
know they lost their job or something or
you know a family member in a hospital
or some or you know a funeral mix-up
type of deal or food poisoning or
something and then all the calls that
will come in after the response for like
you know to kind of be supportive of
that it's just it's captivating
sometimes so yeah and sometimes I think
just want to do like I don't know but I
guess I just want to say thank you so
thank you guys for all your support this
year and thank you guys for coming out
to the show then we got so mad there's
gonna be so many tour dates coming up in
the new year a lot of neat stuff going
on and a lot of neat stuff that that I'm
gonna do and that we're probably that
we're gonna do as a group and and to
just thank you very much man and happy
Thanksgiving to you and yours and you
cannot you know you can always send in
that that uh hash tag that video and
that is relative rodeo and that's where
you hug a relative that don't doesn't
really prefer your arms around them and
see if you could stay on for eight
seconds because that could be pretty
wild
we had Eddie Bravo in the most recent
episode people loved him and you know
what you know what I was watching that
episode and it made me realize how much
I miss Eddie and just when I don't get
to see him you know one thing that was
nice this weekend I got to see Brian
Callens up there and him and him and um
big brown Brandon showers have a show
called fighter and the kids or something
or some I think it's called somebody
beat their children I'm not sure what
it's called but they have a great show
and uh and it was nice to just see to
see him out and about having fun he's
taping a new show called the Goldbergs
and you know I could just feel for some
of his energies how like you know
hopeful and excited he is and and man
Brian Collins is just a great person man
he's really unique and interesting guy
he's so smart and you know I love like
you know I'm fortunate to work in this
business that we're in sometimes but but
you know like having a podcast and
having people that show up and be part
of this community has helped me realize
that like I don't need Hollywood to like
validate me you know it's like I can
create it and be part of a community
where we validate each other and and
that's one thing that I see you know
some guys out here you know and they
have opportunities and stuff like that
it's like I want to see
I just hope that you know la sonam's is
a place where we don't realize our own
values you know we don't see them
because we're our eyes are set on this
kind of prize a little bit and and I've
fallen into that too all of us do and
it's not a something we do that's wrong
it's just something that kind of happens
out here but anyway I don't know what
I'm talking about but I'm just trying to
think about just being grateful you know
there's so many little things I think
about that are great you know even that
I could just even hold an orange you
know imagine just looking at an orange
but not being able to hold it or the
fact you could tell you know hug a
cousin you know do the cousin I mean
let's be honest you could [ __ ]
probably kill a cousin and that's you
know that's bad but it's it's almost
like practice for having a brother or
sister you know you maybe you give you a
cousin a little bit uh you know you make
a little bit of turpentine wine and your
cousin has the first couple sips and
next thing you know y'all doing funeral
services for them but you know that now
you know not to give that to your
brother or sister or your siblings
because a cousin is almost like a
practice like a get-out-of-jail-free
family member you can [ __ ] you could
try out fireworks from your cousin or
put them in a you know a neck brace
that's a little too has too much inches
on it so it makes his neck real soft you
know it makes his neck not capable but a
cousin really is that and this is I
don't know there's just a lot of you
know it's that time of year where you
can do you know just things to be
thankful for
now we could breathe you know that we
could taste jello I mean that we could
you know that we could look somebody in
the eyes and let them know how we feel
that's really powerful that we can feel
sorry you know ah you know sometimes I
feel sorry you know for stuff you know
or that we can feel amazed sometimes I
feel amazed
you know for the first time my life
recently I've been able to realize like
how much people love me I think not like
on a big scale but even just small scale
like family members and friends and
stuff like that I've been able to like
feel their feel their their their care
and affection more than I could in the
past and so man that's powerful
you know it's powerful to be able to
feel that that's really a gift to have
the ability to feel somebody else's
affections and emotions you know to love
somebody else you know and to learn
about love man I had a I had a moment
this week in well you know I gave my
mother a call and you know and I and I
love my mother man and I you know I love
my mother so much and I always you know
uh my mother's always been a great
provider you know she tried as hard as
she could always make sure we had the
birthdays and you know in a little you
know I had an arm big bird sweatshirt
you know something else what else oh I
had a poster Ric Flair you know a poster
uh candy Crawford of you know we had
Tecmo Bowl so you know she made sure
that we had enough you know we had
Christmas holidays Easter you know she
did all the things that you're supposed
to do she just struggled and being able
to create like a you know a loving an
environment where I felt you know loved
I didn't feel unprovided you know we had
we had we had just enough you know but I
just never I think I never felt like
loved as a child you know and this week
I was able to have you know I had this
conversation with my mom and it was just
crazy you know and and she knows that
you know and she feels kind of bad at
she feels bad about I think she just
never learned it she never learned this
whole other world this emotional world
she does learn more
you know what you're supposed to do like
checking a list and I'm not and it's
nothing wrong it's just a world that my
mother didn't know about you know but
you know she said that she you know she
says we had a conversation and she was
talking and she's like you know I really
huh you know apologize if I wasn't able
to be there for you in these ways and
and then I felt bad I apologize because
I realize I couldn't be there for her
you know I realized that the saddest
thing for me was since my mother didn't
you know since I couldn't feel my
mother's love there wasn't that bridge
between us that
I couldn't
show her since
Ridge I couldn't return and show her how
much I loved her either because that's a
two-way you know that bridge is that it
it's the only thoroughfare there and if
your mother you know if you can't if you
know you if my mom would have been
emotionally showing me you know you know
nurture and me and cultivated me
emotionally then I in turn there wasn't
that pathway for me to do the same for
her and I think I realized that I just
want I really want it to be like a very
loving child you know I wanted to be so
much I wanted to be you know I always
thought I was like a daddy's boy but I
think I was like a straight-up mama's
boy you know don't tell anybody either
please don't say anything but but I
didn't get that opportunity because we
didn't have that connection you know so
anyway it was just a what you know it
was just like it was just a wild
conversation and I never you know I
never would have had that like I was
feeling kind of a little bit alone this
week and my mom asked me about it she
doesn't usually ask me about that kind
of stuff and uh it was the first time it
was just like kind of like a moment
where I was able to like kind of tell
her you know that I felt alone that that
that that that that that's how I felt
and then it kind of just took us into
this other conversation you know you
know I think where I just kind of always
felt that way when I was young before I
even had the ability to know that I was
feeling that way I just you know I felt
that way on the inside even if on the
outside everything was you know I was
busy and had stuff to do and I think I
just felt that way
you
just felt like a arm
I just felt like a discomfort or just no
feelings you know or something you know
just this just a just a discomfort a dis
ease if you will but anyhow didn't mean
to get all emo into this [ __ ] but this
is the time of year where you're able to
let people know you love them this is a
time of year were you able to you know
buy somebody a little something get them
a little you know but jug of milk or
some you know suspenders for the baby or
something do something special for
somebody touch your [ __ ] buddy you
know your buddy's gay [ __ ] kissing
bro who gives a [ __ ] you know I'm saying
anything all about you
you're not any dudes [ __ ] don't you
know to be in the dudes to [ __ ] you
know give your buddy $4 let him pull
your hair and jerk off in the corner you
know I'm saying this is mr. Lance's
happy time you know what I'm saying do
what you got to do but so let's say you
know I'm gonna try to this week just not
make things about myself and get out
there and uh and just you know not think
about me man you know but it is a
special time where if you have some you
know if you have things you want to talk
about with the relatives and stuff
you're together and you can bring those
things up and another amazing thing that
can happen is forgiving people man do
forgiveness is the most powerful tool in
the world dude if they had a look you
can take a k47 off the street don't take
forgiveness off the street forgiveness
my god man that's the best dang Jesus
Christ pickaxe right there it's a
beautiful tool let's take two called men
we had two calls today I know it's an
easy week so I'm not gonna bog you guys
down with a big episode
let's see what we got here okay hey Co
hiding hi we I'm calling from Toronto
Ontario Canada hey Kylie in Canada thank
you for calling and you guys just
Thanksgiving I know this I was um
communicating with a buddy of mine the
other day and he told me that it is it
was about a month ago
homeward you were talking to Chris from
Long Island and you were talking about
under appreciating yourself and
experiencing self-doubt to the thing and
I just learned about this it's a
psychological condition called impostor
syndrome and I don't want experience
it's sometimes not good you might be
experiencing a little bit I just want to
share that information with you and what
it is is you start to doubt your own
accomplishments you experience a lot of
self-doubt and you start to think once
you're experiencing success that you
don't deserve to be there I feel like
you might be experiencing a bit of and I
just want you to know that you're not
alone in that and I think that it's
important to just keep pushing onward on
and knowing that you know you're not
your path and you might come from this
underdog perspective and you might come
from this place of humble beginnings and
that will always be a part of you but
you don't have to think that if you
don't remain that person you don't
deserve success and you don't deserve
what's coming to you yeah check it out
read more about it impostor syndrome
love you filled thanks for listening you
ever want to talk to a contemporary
dancer well let's let's chat you know
what I mean well you just did the Samba
through my heart right there that's
sweet of you I appreciate that other
nice words and I'm looking this up as
you were talking about it impostor
syndrome also known as impostor
phenomenon imposter ISM fraud syndrome
is a psychological pattern in which an
individual doubts their accomplishments
and has a persistent internalized fear
of being exposed as a fraud Wow
that's interesting and this is just wiki
this is just Wikipedia ten ways to
overcome impostor syndrome break the
silence separate feelings from fact
accentuate the positive visualized
success and those are a couple of them
but that's interesting you know it is
funny I guess somehow yeah I think there
is when it's funny when you get to the
word when I feel like fear of being
exposed as a fraud it's like yeah yeah I
feel like that it like yeah like maybe
somewhere like in my in my brain you
know I just there's this thing it says
oh you're not you're not good no matter
what you're doing you're not good or
you're not I don't know imposter
syndrome I'll look more into it I
appreciate you sharing that as sweet of
you and you know it's funny I was
talking to Brian Collins last night at
they are at the Comedy Store the
world-famous Comedy Store on Sunset
Boulevard and he was saying man
something sometimes the things about
comedians is that we are just [ __ ] up
you know and I'm not saying this is like
a war with me but that but that there's
something to skew you know just like as
with an athlete he have you know he has
multiple you know ability super
abilities and so that makes them a good
athlete he's like with a comedian you
have you know multiple deficiencies and
so that makes you something wrong with
you but like in a good way like if you
weren't if you didn't have whatever it
was then you wouldn't be how you are you
know you wouldn't you know and I'll say
it as funny as he was saying that I was
thinking man it's like the things I used
to be most ashamed of like you know some
of the environment that I was in and are
the some of the things that are making
me hat are fueling some of the stories
that I'm able to tell today on stage
that is bringing joy to people and so I
guess that is
good point but he said sometimes just
don't fight it and just embrace it and I
think some of that is some of the stuff
I want to do in this you know in this
coming year just be more active and
trying to get myself uh not better but
just yeah just moving forward you know
like instead of like dwelling and kind
of some of this stuff sometimes just get
past it and go on and try experiences
that can help me get to other levels of
comfort and wellness and personal you
know goodness let's take one more call
that came in and both of these were
pretty nice
our producer Nick said I'm thankful to
our producer Nick for all he's done this
year and helping this podcast be a part
of something stay busy with uh you know
a lot of good things Chris Hansen might
be coming on so could you even imagine
Chris frickin Hansen how relaxing is it
to me meet Chris Hansen but not how a
lot of other dudes have met him so and
that's the man from Dateline where
they're trapping dudes with the Gatorade
and stuff with the Gatorade the
children's Gatorade all right let's take
this other call typical deal
so if Lotus from Amarillo Texas cannot
hey Oh hola hola hola Carlos gracias um
man I'll just run to my Instagram feed
and I come across one of your story
feeds and it showed when you were
picking up your nieces man just seeing
their reaction oh yeah I would pick them
for school at Halloween man
onward actions their facial expressions
when they realize that you picking them
out dude and it's just love and joy it
uh put things in perspective for me and
I I just want to say thank you bro for
everything you do it made me realize I
gotta cherish those moments in my life
with my loved ones and I hope you I know
you do for a fact just the justice costs
just more of a little reminder for you
you put that kind of stuff out into the
world just sharing those tools those
that set of your life to us man and it
puts things in perspective to us as well
man so I love you keep doing what you do
bro love you too man that's a nice e to
share yeah you know it's funny to see um
yeah I appreciate you saying that man
you know uh it's nice of making me feel
good you know makes me feel good makes
me feel you know it makes me feel like I
guess embarrassed a little bit too I
don't know like there's part of me and I
don't know if this is just humanity or
our society that does this that makes us
feel like like a shame to like show no
this is in society this is just me I
think like a lot of my life I was like a
shame to show my family and have my
family like be a part of like my my life
in some ways I think I was just angry
growing up I was angry you know that my
father was so old I was angry that we
were poor you know I was angry that I
you know the other people's moms seem to
you know be able to like love their
children differently and you know I was
just ashamed I guess of like who I was
so I didn't you know I think my whole
life I just want to try to get away from
I just tried to get to a place where I
just felt okay you know and I feel bad
about some of those things but nobody
told me when I was a kid you know not to
be ashamed of where I'm from you know
where not to be ashamed of Who I am
nobody told me any of that so I didn't
know you know I just knew and some of it
was you know to take care of myself and
all that anyway this episode got is
getting kind of emo but I appreciate you
saying that man it does make me feel
good these days to be able to you know
to be an uncle and to go around children
and not be a pedophile you know or pet
arm
petty or file it makes me feel good it
makes me feel good to know I could pick
a couple kids up in a truck and I know
the kids I mean that's a solid [ __ ]
feeling to have these days
and I'm just grateful that you know a
higher powers kept me on enough of a
path to see some of these joys and then
I ruined my sister had a child I was so
angry at her I didn't know my sister I
don't really know where you know the
only thing I knew was that I just hadn't
had an opportunity to be angry at her
and since we had fought so much as kids
the only way I knew to even connect with
her was to through through to be angry
and then she you know she had a baby and
then it changed everything you know it
was just something that you could like
love so much you know a little kid and
it just you know and it just reflected
that love so accurately that I could
just you know I could never be mad at my
I mean I could be mad at my sister but I
could never it was different now and
that's one of the things that I think is
gonna solve a lot of racial issues that
they have in the world a lot of racism
and stuff will be solved over time by
joint births you know mixed or people
call them mixed babies where I'm from
but now it's called something else I
don't know but like yeah if a black
family in a white family they they're
their children have a child together
didn't they both are gonna love that
child and when you love something
together and you both love the same
thing and that's really where a lot of
possibility starts for things too for
you to forget the differences so I think
a long term that you'll see a lot of
that in the world and I think that
that's just the way it's supposed to
happen anyway and we're still coming out
of colonial times where people [ __ ]
lost some people lost their whole
civilizations the Mayans [ __ ] Umbra they
made a shitty calendar and they showed
up too they showed up two days early to
getting their ass beat and they got beat
you know who else bred the britains
[ __ ] everybody man they enslaved half
of the world they they eliminated so
many cultures a lot of people lost you
know Native Americans they got popped
off when when I'm
Americans left from Britain they got
popped off slate Africa slaves got
jacked out by you know the French or the
Spanish whoever it was I think Leandro
Cortes or something his boys down there
you know doing the bait and switch on a
lot of brothers and selling them into
work you know it's like something just
happened but I think over time and as
the world become more of a melting pot
you know beige power that's would always
say beige power you know I feel like
it's the direction we're headed in and
ultimately it's it's a solution I think
says some things you know I think we can
all like because it it really is seeing
the same thing and loving something
that's similar that does bring really
bring people together you know I mean as
much as I want to [ __ ] you know be
Tony Montoya and you know shoot up the
universe and get all coke down I don't
know if that's always the best solution
you know but anyway I don't know how
this I don't know how any of this gets
into anything but we'll take some calls
in the last week you know going in the
last week two responses to things and
stuff but I just wanted to say thank you
to everybody you don't want to say thank
you for making you know this podcast has
changed a lot of my you know well just a
lot of my I don't know it's just changed
you
you know it's made me feel
it's like the one thing that's been
consistent every week you know I mean
it's been a couple of other you know
couple people and but uh you know and
sometime it's sometimes I've chosen this
podcast over over everything in a lot of
ways you know over just having this
opportunity and having this space and so
I just want to say thank thank you to
the listeners for you know sharing
things that are going on in your lives
you know I get a lot of messages just
say hey Theo thank you you know I'm five
months sober I am you know I am you know
I heard something your podcast that made
me think or made me feel and and I you
know that I think that means a lot to me
man because uh all I really I think I
when I was young I wanted so much to
have somebody around my life that made
me feel something that wasn't you know
sad because I just always felt sad or
shame do you know and it's almost scary
sometimes to have something to be proud
of
you know it's such kind of it's such
rare tear it's such unchartered kind of
territory for me to really take pride in
something and not just like let my ego
be proud of something but to actually
really feel like pride on the inside
that's why I think it really just takes
a while to set in to my skin because I'm
just really not used to it but I'm
grateful to have the opportunity
grateful for my producers you know
premature Nick Nick at Nite he's
actually you know he says he went
full-term who knows we'll have him as a
guest I think sometime so we can learn
more about him Chris Perez you know me
at hermano who you know helped this
podcast scoot off you know really
putting his two cents I he doesn't
communicate I haven't heard from him
recently but you know there were
countless nights and times when he was
there to help out and then just all
these guys around me you know these
other podcasters that include me in
their world and then make me feel a part
of their community you know and uh man
it's just this podcast community's kind
of giving me like a brotherhood or like
a team that I've never really kind of
had in some ways and it's just man it's
great you know enough about me but thank
you to you I hope you have a wonderful
Thanksgiving you know I want to see
those videos if you can do that relative
rodeo hashtag relative rodeo hug
somebody in your family that maybe don't
want that hug see if you could stay on
for eight seconds you know and that's
beautiful and I want to say thank you to
to my patreon supporters and these are
people who support on patreon and that's
the money that goes towards getting
camera people to help with the single
moms and doing the doing the the new
gameshow stuff that we're doing too so
so I'm gonna rattle those off thank you
guys be good to yourselves
happy Thanksgiving we have done el
Rawlings on our Thanksgiving episode so
finally we got a real I'm talking a lo
que out brother this dude has tats on
his straight up there get filming we got
a real
at our Montenegro in here you know and
I'm not saying that and I'm saying that
in Spanish so filter that through
espanol before you come at me but we got
a real a real guy that I love talking to
about all types of stuff so I'm really
looking forward to being over again into
some conversations with him but um all
right let's take us out with a little
bit of gun and then we'll we'll rattle
off Aaron Jones Aaron Stein Addison I
totally know Adriana at Ananda's I eat
in Duffy Alaskan rock vodka and do two
here in Alaska brah
you better be rockin vodka Alex Hitchens
Alex person
Alex Sedaris Alexandra Contreras Amanda
Sherman Andre Agassi Leon E Andrew
volleys and eMac on hello Regan Angie
Angeles Anna Wintour Anthony shoots
Arielle Nicole Ashley Kenickie Audrey
Harlan Austin killer
Ben Ben Degnan Ben limes ooh damn boy
you probably got a drinking problem
Benjamin straight Street Big Easy Brian
Reinhold Bubba Hodge california outlaw
Calvin Doyle Campbell Heil
Karla Huffman hey Carla Casey Roberts
Casey rude soul Chad salt see I'll see
you in Lexington Christian from
Bakersfield Christopher staff Clint Lyle
Cody Cummins Cody Kenyon Cody Marsh Dan
Draper Dan ray David Smith David Wyrick
Donald blackwell do AG Maajid do AG Majd
my felicity a black Felix Ren
Gabrielle Almeida Garrett Blankenship
ginger Levesque Greg H gun squad Gary
got a senior Jakob Ortega Jakob rice
yucca Bryce sound like a damn dish James
asked more James banks James bound off
so close Jamison flood
the musician James Bragg Jason Haley
Jeffrey Lucero also has sent in some
beautiful music Jenna Sundy Jer Jerry
Zhang Jerry Zhang bro that Hebrew maybe
Chinese mix beautiful Jessie with them
Thank You Jessie Jo done
Joey des rois dis roar Sears Joey
piemonte a John catch John Ross
Josh cowgirl Justin L Justin Marku
Justin Shoei Karen Sullivan Katie Doyle
Kennedy Kenton call Kevin best who
wonder if that's Kennedy that was on MTV
that's on Fox and Friends now Kevin
flurry Kevin best my t-shirt man Kiera
par Kirk Cahill kiss kiss Shalin
Christine Rogers lacy briefs Meister
Laura Williams Lauren crib Leighton
fields Logan the atman Luke Denton mark
Bentley Matt Holland Matt came and Matt
Leftwich Matt as I'm Matthew price
Matthew Sizemore Matthew snow
Oh 8-ball daddy Megan daily Megan luck I
see Michael Baltar Oh Mike PO my boy out
there in Arkansas Mike Sarah no Mitchell
Watson mo no mo cure Ned Eric what up
Ned Ned is a friend of mine that I've
seen in five different states just
because he happened to be working in
different states when I was there
performing pretty cool
Nicky butcher Nico Freeman Dean Nick's
by mouth / Old MacDonald oh that's the
future right there old scrote McCracken
Owen lied Patti J passenger shaming
thank you passenger shaming they've been
so supportive on Instagram as well go
follow them Paul Flores one of the
smartest men I know a minimum semester
at sea a beautiful man beautiful family
Phillip James key Jenkins Ranger Rick
Renee Nicole hello Renee rindy a Robin
tattoo
Ryan crafts Ryan Forrest Ryan Jordan
Ryan cram ring Ryan Walsh Sam negan
Sarah Anderson Scott Lucy
Swain hi I'm Scott Swain Scott Swan
would be good name - Shane Pacheco
Shannon Schulte Stace a blessing step
fan Jeffries it's a dope name step fan
step fan Jeffries dude yeah man
Stephanie Claire Steve cor Lou that
madman Steven some some some Joe Susanne
O'Reilly that dude with the paper bag
the Asian hamster gang the shit-faced
chef Tim greener Tim oz Healy
Timothy Ironmen Tom in rural North
Carolina
Tommy read it Travis vowel and sometimes
y ty Oliver Tyler honked and Tyler
shaver Victor Montana
William Morris my boy bill Morris up
there from the bay I love you bill and
Zach Johnson those are our patreon errs
man as always this episode is brought to
you by gray block pizza 18:11 Pico
Boulevard Santa Monica on the way to the
beach gray block pizza get that hitter
happy Thanksgiving man be good to
yourselves guys and thank you for being
good to me man thank you very very very
much
I'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could I be so far from my
home and my mind is somewhere else but
when I found it our patch up where it's
been grown now I'm just floating on the
breeze and I feel up full and like these
leaves that must be cornerstone happy
Thanksgiving guys
little town for me to sell their part
and break
me